Jacky's in Logan Utah hi Jackie how are
you hiya Dave how are you better than I
deserve what's up um okay well when I
was 19 my mom helps me get into a
private art college and put me a lot of
debt here and a half later I was $50,000
in debt and she was bankrupt and um I
graduated I transferred schools and
graduated just last August in elementary
education is art and I got married two
years ago about and we just barely had a
baby unexpectedly and my husband people
graduate in May and civil engineering we
both are working the problem is I have
that the problem has has is that he
doesn't want to help pain like that
right now and my payments are coming up
and he doesn't think we can do it my mom
helped to offer like help to pay it but
she don't put that on her she's broke
yeah well she has a job but she has
never been good with money so so are you
working um after maternity leave my
shift at where I worked I do in home
care service got it's for something or
not you're teaching them no I didn't
graduate it was a license it's just kind
of an interdisciplinary studies things
okay so it is so fun when does your
Haven graduate you'll graduate in May so
I was like so let me get this straight
he married you and he had a baby with
you but he doesn't think that the debt
you have is his problem
well yeah exactly he said that before
yeah I mean what'd you replenish well I
think so too
he just wants to like save up money well
that'd be nice but what's he gonna do
just when they come and cart you away
what are they gonna do then so you're
just gonna raise the kid well are like
have a shirt I don't know what we do
then either so um you want to just save
up money they're not going to call you
away I'm going okay and then like yeah
hold are you gonna work no more in 25 I
also have art business and I don't know
how to much I don't know how much to
charge for my artwork yeah yeah yeah
that's everything I need help okay well
there's several things number one you're
going to have to like a lot of artists
get your hands around the idea that that
you're going to have to do something in
our culture that makes you money and for
some artists that's a distressing thing
to actually discover that but you'll
have to do that because you have to make
money for your family and have them in
order to raise this child and to and to
be able to work your way through these
deaths the same with your husband as
your husband running up debt as well
getting his degree no he's really frugal
actually oh no he doesn't have any debt
nicely okay
and where does the money come from that
keeps food on the table and the lights
turned on at your house um he works and
well we are living off of savings right
now actually from what we earned in the
summer he had an internship awesome no
around me or probably gonna run out of
money so when you got both are working
or saved up money yeah I got you okay
all right well the thing is this if you
want to be successful in handling money
as a married couple and you want to have
a high-quality marriage the only
possibility for that the only
possibility for that long term is for
you to learn to handle money together
and to share each other's burdens that's
why when you walk down the aisle the
old-fashioned wedding vows said for
richer for poorer in sickness and in
health for richer for poorer and now you
are one and the super-old that the old
time Val said unto the all my worldly
goods I pledge because what we were
saying was was that we were becoming one
we're not roommates we're your problems
aren't my problem
problems are now my problem your
victories are now my victories and vice
versa that's what good husbands and
wives do in a good marriage and he's
really crummy at that right now yeah and
so on you guys have got to learn to do
this together and it's in his best
interest as well because he now has a
child that he's responsible for tada so
what is the most efficient way to handle
money the most productive way to handle
money it's for couples to share it and
do the handling of the money together
that's the only way it works and so I'd
recommend that the two of you go to
Financial Peace University our nine week
class I'm not trying to sell you
something I will give it to you if he
will go if he will not go you cannot
have it it is a conditional gift he must
agree to go you must agree to go and I
will show you how what I've shown four
and a half million other people that
have gone through that class how to
handle money and it will include the two
of you doing it together which is what a
good husband a good wife do
by definition until you do that you're
not on the good list says Santa Claus so
hold on the line Kelly Daniel will pick
up and we'll get you signed up for that
if you can get him to attend with you
that's simple
you